hi there and welcome to the app clinic i
am dr. reto Meier and I'm dr. Ian knee
Lewis we are not real doctors but we are
qualified to operate on Android apps in
several states and US territories the
app clinic is a weekly opportunity to
take a look at some great Android apps
and talk a little about what we can do
to make them even better right so today
we're looking at travel planning and
booking apps I think the idea is we've
got the holidays coming up we all go
somewhere to get away from our families
absolutely so let's take a look at the
apps that will help us plan that okay so
we have a number of apps I'm gonna have
a look at today we're going to start
with world scope webcams four-point-oh
we've also got kayak Hipmunk and
TripAdvisor so the idea here is they're
all apps which are going to help you to
plan your trip to make the bookings for
your trip rather than apps which are
going to help you while you are on
holidays we are going to look at those
later we had some great suggestions in
the moderator queue for those apps rest
assured we will be checking them out as
well I think we're going to start with a
world scope web camera which is a little
bit of a twist on what we wanted to see
you know we were thinking more of
planning and booking I in terms of as a
kayak or Expedia that sort of service
but this one's an interesting twist what
World Cup webcams does is lets you check
out your destination before you go nice
so it'll let you look at webcams pretty
much anywhere so oh no worries no
worries it's cool we were on a streak
there one day without an accident just
37 out 20 that's such a nice intro
animation it is well thank you so what
world scope does is lets you take a look
at different webcams across the world
and see what's going on so for instance
here's here's a cool iñaki where I used
to live sin Dogma square I was hoping
we'd catch a riot no such London that's
a shame yeah they seem to be doing all
right
a lot of these webcams just refresh
every every few minutes every hour some
of them refresh much more frequently
than that but you can at least get an
idea of what's happening where you want
to go and sort of one up on google
street view that's in a way you're able
to add to favorites with the star able
to refresh refresh the webcam and
there's a huge list of options okay
that's eyes my my favorite of course is
show on map because what I'm really
asking is how close is this webcam to my
hotel so we've already been burned that
one alright so let's uh let's take a
look show on map oh they're using a
mystery maps nice they certainly are
it's interesting it's a little bit rough
uh mostly because they I can see where
we are on the map but that doesn't
really help me well I know if I
necessarily as specific as you'd like it
to think right if i zoom in yeah um so
but in general you know you can bet nice
jab solutely this is my old hood time
town well yeah Hillary's boat harbor
they've only got a black-and-white
webcam but that's cool an audio-only
before and now they're all the way up to
the 50s excellent I thought they were
using a semaphore flags to to explain
what the current temperature and
conditions were like well that's that's
how the TCP connection is of course
physically tcp / sun deport all right so
yeah very interesting we love and I'm
not you know obviously doesn't help you
in the travel planning process any more
than this but I not a bad idea yeah
absolutely would be interesting to see
features like this integrated into other
apps aren't you indeed using intense to
to allow you to view vid webcams of
areas around the hotels you want a book
so maybe an opportunity for some of the
other apps that we're looking at today
to link into an app like this absolutely
alright let's go ahead and move on
alright so the next step we wanted to
look at was a hit monk oh yes if you
have you check this one out i checked
look at the first year here didn't you i
did actually and then we didn't
rearrange them into an order that makes
sense that we haven't seen it the whole
that cool movie girlie stuff that that's
not a long time so long we don't even
have a script for this if I was reading
off the teleprompter now I'd be saying
hello everyone my name is reto Meier
well this week in Android development I
totally want to get that as a clip okay
so Hipmunk hipmunk is more of an
all-in-one now hit monkey I full
disclosure we're friends with the guys
that made this software and the least
one of them used to work here a really
cool little piece of software
unfortunately isn't going to help us a
lot where we are right now which is uh
let's see 77 state Georges Terrace in
Perth oh nice I have a friend of mine
has a new bar and restaurant in exactly
that location is it is it Lala rook it
might be that's great so I so what
anyone does is lets you all this back
out here then so this is the first part
first page of hit monk it's a dashboard
with two items that's trying not to be a
dashboard and I can either do what I got
to be a list rather than a dash yes
hotel search or flight search now the
truth is I'm not gonna find any hotels
in Perth they just don't exist it's that
right but you know if I let's say that
I'm planning a trip and this is actually
one thing that I found a little odd I
felt like the first thing I wanted in an
application like this was not to
actually see my location but you know
let's well we'll go over that a little
bit more so let's the trip that I want
to take us to Venice not Venice Venice
Florida Venice Italy yeah hmm yeah seem
to what no let's I give up let's go to
Venice Florida or Valencia Venezuela
that's pretty much the same thing you
know when I travel I'm easy ok now it's
got a little progress bar down there and
notice it's filling in all the hotels
that it can find that fit my definition
of what I wanted ok and you can filter
using the settings lug and you can get a
heat map to let you know what's good and
bad in terms of price you can also do a
flight search and their flight search
that's apparently ok Porto Honolulu that
is perfect hmm we'll go ahead and do
that it's a really cheap flight to yeah
apparently awesome all right they do
take a while but I hope we can get to
this screen in a reasonable amount of
time because they have probably the best
flight search screen I've ever seen yeah
yeah so they they allow you to search by
different categories you know price and
when you depart and when you arrive but
they also let you sort by the sinkhole
agony I think that's a coolest thing in
the world it's a combination of the
departure and arrival time the total
time of the flight how bad your seat is
a bunch of other things I and it also
lets you see on the milliner yeah now
the nice thing I think we don't have it
set up here but we this will actually
integrate with your calendar so if you
have events uh you know for instance you
see whether you gonna make it there in
time make sure that you leave after a
reasonable period after you lost meeting
exactly like for instance it might say
oh here we've got the you know Android
developers weekly and I would say well I
don't care about that so ignore it and
there we go it also color codes the
airline's but I haven't figured it out
yet I was hoping at first it would be
frequent flyer program yeah and it's not
um I think it's it's actually based on
the color scheme of the analog
because Cathay Pacific is that olive
green Emirates is that sort of red color
so that could be it japan airlines that
I'm of their gray I don't know yeah it
looks like it could be based around
something like that anyway just a really
cool thing it also marks your flights as
to whether they have Wi-Fi or not a
couple of other convenient little things
nice so that's cool all right I let's go
ahead and move on quickly go over kayak
so kayak is one of a family of apps that
I think are really just a gateway to the
web service yeah um they're all very
similar but I think it's pretty well
done you have the opportunity to search
for hotels and you know check-in it with
your check-in and check-out time you can
search your flights and you can also
search any number of other things
including your airport information not
cede information a surprise about that
and flush or I might have just missed it
but also you can even even do your
packing list here nice it's one of the
the full service model of droid it's an
all-in-one flight planner nice and well
let's take a look at the apps that you
looked at yeah so I had looked at a
couple this morning when I wasn't
messing around in keynote and two apps
one is fast booking and the other
tripadvisor so we can have a look at
fast booking first which is this up here
I can hit the icon so this is sort of
based primarily around just the booking
part of the app and much like you know
most of the other apps are looking at
you know you have that ability to you
know basically be able to specify
details find out if there are hotels
available so this app isn't actually
available in the u.s. it so it's a
European app but I thought you know why
not have a look so one of the things
which struck me immediately upon looking
at this app is that you sort of end up
straight in this page where you're you
know ready to book hotels
no real you know there's no additional
features there's no flights it's really
just hotel bookings if we search around
me i'm going to suspect that it's not
going to work so i'm going to put in now
let's put in venice cos we never got to
go there last time yeah and search it
was i I have occasionally wanted exactly
this just something that would take my
current location and tell me what would
you like a nice God yeah but that was
only when I was like backpacking around
the world cool Jamie yeah you've really
got to be in an odd position did you use
that feature you know that that being
said it's not it's not the most
ridiculous you know I know that there
has been in occasions in my past when I
haven't had a backpack but have still
been looking for somewhere sort of lost
seven out absolutely you know when you
when you rent a car at Heathrow and
decide to drive up to Scotland to visit
distilleries I mean whenever you're
tired you want to our linear is for
something about exactly so you go
through and it's got the the usual
things that you would expect from a
hotel booking appt you've got
descriptions star ratings find out about
the rooms galleries reviews all those
sorts of things so it's it's a fully
featured hotel booking at but doesn't
really go beyond beyond that now if it
certainly has really nice hotel booking
features i mean it i don't have any of
the other episode these galleries no
this is very true they're really you
know going that extra step i think to
make sure that you can see exactly what
it is you're going to be getting no
roots wood-ridge when i travel a lot
right i mean were you we've been around
the world I and I've done a lot of book
a mostly on websites and i will say i
usually have three or four tabs open one
is for the flights to try and figure out
what the best times are maybe airlines
to figure out which alliance they belong
to or how many miles i'm going to get
i'll probably have seat you were open so
i can see you know if I'm getting a
senior the bathroom or not absolutely
and i'll also have the individual hotel
page is open to try and find out what
the rooms are like weather policies are
like so to me an all-in-one travel app
would be a godsend absolutely absolutely
we'd have to do this a lot and often one
whit
traveling it's for some industry
conference CES mobile or Congress and so
you know you're really in a situation
where there aren't a lot of rooms a lot
of people are coming at the same time
and you having to do this for work so
it's not pleasure you're not trying to
you know you're not enjoying the process
of finding a place to stay you just wave
have all the information in one place
make sure that it's going to be as
pleasant as it can be exactly we
actually came up with some some
prescriptions for a good travel out but
before we get to them let's take a look
at that last out one more apt to look at
which is tripit or so not tripit
tripadvisor i like right if any app
which i strip at the beginning of it
yeah so tripadvisor is Sir advisors
great so I use this website a lot and my
wife especially uses it a lot to help
plan our holidays and so this is getting
a little bit closer to this full service
model you can see here that we've got
hotels restaurants things to do flights
near me now that whole sort of thing so
even you know from booking the hotels to
begin with before you start your your
travel let's go with current location I
think that is what it does by default
oops so now this is something that I did
want to did want to talk about really
briefly it really wants me to rate the
app I hate this I hate this feature I
hate people telling me you know please
validate me tell me how awesome I am if
I like the app I will go and give it a
good review yes this makes me want to
give it a bad it feels a little
desperate but it does you know I
honestly I think that we may feel that
way just because we look at so many apps
I guess but I mean it's to me it's it's
breaking the magic right and so if we've
talked about this a lot and the sort of
app that I want to use doesn't make me
think about the fact that it's a nap you
know it's just going to be part of the
phone something that I'm always going to
have installed on any device that I have
right it's true I don't think you'd ever
get into your Bentley and have your
Bentley say hey do you like driving this
car maybe you'd like to talk about it on
Facebook tell your friends how much you
love driving you Bentley it's it's a
little desperate it's a little needy and
I'm just in this up in particular but I
hit back now then okay it's gone it
knows that I say no but actually you'll
find that as we continue to navigate
through it is going to pop up again and
again
which is you know oh yeah I think the
only way that I've been happy with that
it is if I if I see that as a single
menu option in the overflow exactly oh
yeah right i was gonna write that app
okay I can you know and for some reason
I'm completely clueless about how to
launch Google Play I installed the app
in Google Play and use the reviews to
decide whether I wanted it but I still
can't figure out how to review it okay
then it's article thing sure we'll stop
beating on that horse so the real key
here is that it has all of the
tripadvisor stuff on here so it's got
huge number of traveler reviews and
these are really valuable reviews which
a lot of people put a lot of time and
effort into you know providing that
information there's photos from from the
from people who have actually stayed in
these places all done with nice you know
few pages so you can see exactly what
you're looking at it's quite nice
although we can't really read the
content so much when when we're talking
about the android app because a lot of
great services exist on the web that's
the sister and not all of them have
great android apps to go along with that
more content yeah no absolutely and then
this is a really good example of trying
to take something where you already have
this great content and leveraging it on
what is really rapidly becoming the way
that people access their information I
think the things like travel especially
so because you can sit on your couch
with your Nexus 7 and flick through all
these hotels it can be a nice experience
absolutely I mean the one thing that
strikes me immediately when i look at
this app is wow I think everyone on the
design team is probably carrying a phone
by a different manufacturer yes that
definitely does seem to be the case and
we'll go into a little bit more detail
about the specifics around some of the
design issues but you can straight away
see you know we've got these kind of
weird-looking tabs the two small buttons
here we've got the action bar which is
nice but then we're not using sort of a
standard up affordance to sort of
control the navigation but which more
detail level I like that you know again
we happen to be in my hometown of Perth
that the number 6 attraction in the the
best recommendation here is the Swan
River
it's a river I like rivers rivers are
great and a skyscraper I guess that's
number 97 but anyway I digress so we've
got things to see places to eat places
to stay all sort of put it put there for
you two to observe which is nice you
know it gives you that ability to be
able to create your entire trip all in
one place oh nice alright so those are
the apps that we're looking at today
let's go in a little deeper and put them
up and see what's going on let's really
get in there and duh and perform a
clinic so right we've put together some
prescriptions and I know you spent a
little bit more time on the app's this
week that I have answer well why don't
you tell spokes with it what does it
take to make a great travel booking and
planning out well first as always you
need to be consistent with the Android
design guide why is that important
because we want to have a consistent
experience and users always know how to
do what they want to do now remember
last week we talked about camera apps
and we said that they should be pretty
and consistent in this case of course
you want to be pretty but they don't
need to be artistic yeah more than
anything else they need to be useful and
consistent and probably also branded
yeah absolutely you want to make sure
people know what they're using and I
think one thing which is consistent here
you know we're talking about
particularly when it comes to hotels and
tourist attractions to make good use of
photos you know that's really what's
going to sell people on a destination is
being able to see that so we want to see
nice big rich images absolutely no
travel apps just need to be
location-aware most apps do but today so
when you're when you're traveling
obviously you're almost always going to
be starting from your current location
or somewhere nearby it should integrate
with my digital life and I can't
overemphasize this this is really really
important to me I want to make sure that
the tools that I use to keep track of my
life like calendar like Google+ or
Facebook or Twitter are integrated into
this tool so that my travel plans and my
real life my regular life can fit
together I and you know I mean maybe
this is just me but I don't
honestly sometimes forgotten that I was
going to go to China until the last
minute wait is that today right it's
like i would say i would literally make
plans like oh yeah I can totally go out
with you on Tuesday night oh yeah I'm
gonna be in shame we want something that
plans your entire trip a trip is not
just a flight it's a flight a hotel its
transportation to and from the hotel
yeah this thing's to do random tenders d
crap that my wife lights finally we want
something that's going to let me do the
entire set of transaction by everything
related to that trip on the device I
don't want to have to go to a website I
I definitely don't want to pop up a
browser window awesome Noah and I don't
want to have to save something and then
log into my account on a computer to be
able to complete things you know just
gonna be able to do everything right
from whatever device i'm using so let's
keep those in mind to take a look at
some of these apps absolutely and what
we do that i want to remind folks that
we we have producers Scott main keeping
an eye on our YouTube and Google+ events
so if you have any questions or comments
about the apps that we're looking at
maybe ways in which the you know what
are the prescriptions you guys think it
takes to make a great app do let us know
and we will try and answer those
questions as well absolutely producer
Scott we have anything interesting on
the comment stream right now um not
seeing a whole lot of interaction shame
on you shame on you viewers talking
producer Scott is he's lonely very
lonely he's just checking his email he's
got this frown on his face yeah I really
don't know what you guys talking about
he just moved down here from Seattle and
the Sun is killing him it's foggy and
overcast in Mountain View today but even
still even still the Sun is killing him
and this doesn't look like September it
looks like late July all right let's go
play with that yeah yeah take a little
deeper look starting with world scope
now this is going to be a quick one
because there's not a lot to this out
yeah
but I did have some issues with not just
our prescriptions for travel app which
don't necessarily apply to this
particular out but with the UI the first
problem that I had is that this area
here at al this looks like a viewpager
it right yeah it looks like you should
be able to fling that around no however
this is ok so the a lockable right now I
think that they may have done that
because when you get to the map which is
zoomed way way way out it's a little bit
difficult to operate this as a view
pager and that's understandable but yeah
I don't feel like that's necessarily an
excuse for making it completely broken
everywhere else yeah I mean there are
ways that you can sort of do an edge
swipe as well so you can still have a
view pager type functionality while
you've still got a full screen multi pan
you know it also bothered me that the
search tab doesn't actually search it's
just the map view so it's more browse
like browse fine let's just write and
then I have to do it such as to actually
now they are doing the regular search
bar in the action bar so that's very
good I'm not the nice the right way
which is nice to see you've got your
appropriate up affordance there to
escape out of it which is it's nice to
see you can see here one thing that I
noticed was that we're actually cutting
off the name of the app while we're in
portrait mode so it seems like this
might be an opportunity to drop the name
completely and just stick with the logo
rather than having an abbreviated name
which just kind of makes it look
squished mm-hmm you also might give some
serious thought to completely getting
rid of these tabs and making those a
navigation drop-down so obviously you've
decided that you don't want viewpoint
view pager activities and if you don't
want a view pager then being able to
just tap on the app icon have a drop
down navigation is going to be just as
fast pretty much just as discoverable
and you get this screen real estate
thing if I'm if I'm not mistaken I
believe that if you actually use the
standard action bar tab
it will switch between having a
drop-down navigation in portrait mode
and if you've got space so landscape
mode or on on tablets will actually
switched to a tab layout instead very
nice Kevin that would be very cool and I
mentioned before to you that once you're
on this map zooming in is not
particularly efficient and if you
already know where you want to go being
able to zoom in on the specific location
that you wanted is nigh impossible right
the best way I've found to do that is to
actually tap this key a little place is
key and that'll show you things that you
can zoom in on gotcha and then you can
just keep hitting up right until your
ends readjusting and just feeling
frustrated the whole time right this is
something where honestly it might be
better to just integrate with a nice
Maps API or at least give some thought
to how you would zoom in directly I
actually thought this button might do it
but I say that is exactly the opposite
of what I wanted that's interesting as
well I look at that icon and the first
thing I think is a full screen like I
expect it to just get go full screen and
it doesn't so that's a little bit
confusing so how can i zoom well I have
to actually select it a menu which wow
haha okay 1995 called they want your
model of user interaction back yeah
that's definitely something you want to
have front center that ability to really
zoom in but it's it's an interesting app
and i think you know they've done
something kind of cool there yeah so the
scores here are aren't fair at all we we
scored based on travel and booking as
opposed to this sort of niche app but
let's take a look at what we've got here
um I brought the suspect that the school
is out from Caesar is the end we know I
can see where we were going now yeah
this girls will go after we've discussed
the app oh now we're going to bounce
bounce through each of the apps first
and then go back and have a look at how
each of them score don't know for us
prescriptions alright so the next dad
what's up let's bring up kayak and dig a
little deeper there as well right right
did we want to bring up kayak canoe when
bring up it monk ah ah ah I'm looking at
next slide instead of current slide I am
absolutely not the only one making
mistakes today no okay hipmunk okay
first thing they really did make some
efforts to be more Android hmm
unfortunately some of those efforts felt
a little misguided for instance it was
actually in the end they said oh yeah we
try to make it more Android ii by
squaring off the corners so they're not
rounded I'd ready I can say that yeah
you know what we don't have an entire
hour to discuss that so let's just let's
just point out that these buttons down
here in the corner should almost
certainly be on an action bar absolutely
how many our actions right and they are
now the icons here look like more or
less standard I've Android icons but
they don't do the same thing okay I the
this looks like settings right they
really corner looks like said ah no it
is filter oh there is a filter iphone
icon yeah I settings should actually
take you to settings I should point out
as well we don't want settings to be an
action it should probably leave in yoga
flow many examples enigma flaminia
unless settings is absolutely crucial
for your application is nice uh ya uzhe
metas con oh very cool yeah now this is
the list icon it's a little confusing
but it'll allow you to view the hotels
by list okay here's the problem
it'll pop up a host and tap to view this
list of hotels please do not press this
button again so this is this is a
scolding toast yeah yeah oops so holding
it wrong instead I mean you're popping
up the toast to tell them what to do why
don't you just do it yeah now you're
never you're never not looking at a map
in this this is true i noticed that when
i was sort of playing around with the
app earlier trying to find you know is
there a sort of a step back from that
and it's not it's all matte base which
is kind of a nice idea you have this
sort of rich interface you can see
exactly where you're looking where
you're going to stay yep now I really
want you to go to write its Laura yeah
see if i type in Venice Italy so this is
still wants me to go to Florida now if I
dismiss this to dismiss the keyboard and
say search then it works interesting now
while it's working we can complain a
little bit about the progress bar so the
progress bar is completely wrong it
doesn't look like any progress bar that
exists in Android at all and it's not
clear exactly what I'm going to do with
I guess the axis for cancel i mean
that's make sense usually the case um
you know that's nice but it's down at
the very bottom of the screen will be
very yet very small touch target would
be very easy to accidentally hit the
HOME key I'm not loving it yeah it just
kind of looks tacked on you know I'd
really much prefer to see something like
a refreshing image in the in the action
bar something to show that progress is
happening much like you would see if you
hit refresh on gmail or something like
that now once i'm there it's very cool i
can talk a little heat map so i can see
what kind of vice is in the area oh
that's wrong then this is full of ice
everywhere
his vice it's a very good question he's
a location-specific or does it figure
out where you are now and then that's a
good question i think they're selling
unrolled something okay so really nice
features but the the you i could use
some work now once i actually get in
here you know we've got the the nice
stuff inside oh we got the beeping gets
a tripadvisor reviews and night yeah so
I like that that's nice uh would maybe
like a few more pictures um you can see
they've they've done some weird things
like they've got their own oh you see
how that bounces around quite right yeah
um so it's cool i mean you know somebody
obviously spent some time with that they
certainly didn't make it worse my only
concern is that when you write your own
unless it's doing something that is
incredibly important to your app you're
sort of opening yourself up for some
real problems later on sure you know we
love the bouncy feel now but later on if
the android platform goes in a different
direction everyone else is going to pick
up that updated feel and you're going to
be stuck with this thing that is going
to end up feeling updated so that
there's no problem in taking some of the
built-in framework components and
modifying and having them adding a
little bit of urine spice to it but it
is something you want to do carefully
knowing that at any time you could run
the risk of starting to look aged and
all it's also very difficult to get back
to where you were yeah I noticed that
the navigation isn't quite like really
easy to back out of something in fact
they have multiple ways to back out of a
screen including the up affordance and
an action button and the back button but
then to get back into that hotel search
you gotta research
that's a pain it's one of the things
which which I noticed about this happen
or something I've seen quite a lot off
is sort of you navigate into something
which has a view pager and then that
view pager has entirely different
contexts so it's like this is about the
hotel this is reviews and as you're
swiping through it makes sense but you
kind of feel like you're navigating
through the app because it's a sort of a
totally different UI and then I often
find myself then heading back to them
you know go back to say the previous you
know the previous view pager which isn't
the behavior that should happen but then
i find myself back here but here at the
at the search screen and then i have to
do the whole thing again i have to wait
for it to complete and so you kind of
want a way to prevent that accidental
back behavior from really ruining your
day now what's even worse is that here
i'm going through exactly the same dance
that i had to go and last time which is
extremely disturbing considering that if
i go all the way back here and try a
flight search it has a recent searches
option yeah so why doesn't it have a
recent searches option for hotels I'm
actually more likely to need that since
it's not all composed because I haven't
necessarily decided where I'm going to
stay or which particular suburb we're
going to be in and I do a lot of
different hotel searches tific I don't
want to go back to them yeah typically
going to do you know several different
hotel searches in different areas you
want to be able to compare them easily
and I think that's really something you
want to be able to do really quickly is
have this list of hotels that you're
considering and just be able to click
through them and now notice it is
location where's it found out you know
where we're at I think yeah we're going
to Honolulu sure no no no I think we're
going to Venice
now again now see interesting this is
the most interesting match that I've
seen actually okay you know what screw
bettis we're gonna go to gun athens nice
right now this is a part of do you
really like this is a good UI I can you
know I'm gonna go over Thanksgiving nice
no better time to go it happens um now
the interesting thing here so I looked
at this app a little while ago and
you've correctly you know done you're
from and two dates I made the mistake
that the first time and i'm not sure if
it'll work of just pressing the data i
was going to leave and then hitting done
and that'll give you a one way and that
gives me a one-way flight and then i
couldn't for the life of me figure out
how to turn a one-way flight into a
return flight until someone had the good
sense to just you know click a second
date exactly so it's really easy to use
interface it's wonderful but it's not
discovering exactly so that's something
you want to consider is you know chances
are in most cases people are looking for
a return flight and so you want to make
it really obvious if if they're only one
selected one date that this is going to
result in a in a one way and that
perhaps they should click a return date
if they want to have returned now here's
an example of a case where they may not
have completely thought through their
layout because as you can see over here
the calendar is very nicely formatted
most of the really important data has
been put into you know bold fonts that
are a good size good readability for
this screen but then you've got three
areas the two buttons and this little
area up here that says tap Done to
continue its just sort of taking up
space telling me something that i'm sure
i already knew and those are in a tiny
and almost illegible font all right and
i think a lot of this comes from making
some assumptions about the devices that
you programmed on especially when it
comes to screen size and density
remember that some screens are
relatively small but incredibly dense
and if you're not thinking about that
sort of HD density
then you're gonna have a bad time and
infectious while you had that screen
back up I'm going to do the search
excellent thanks lu lu so one of the
interesting things i noted this is when
you've got that calendar view up it
comes up as a dialogue now i know why it
comes up as a dialogue is because if
you're on the web and you need to choose
a calendar entry you want to put it in a
dialogue you want to put a little screen
which comes up rather than having the
entire display taken up with it on your
phone that was already covering ninety
percent of the screen why not just make
it a full screen activity and have a
behave in that same way have a done
affordance up the top so that you can
just continue that way rather than
having this sort of weird pop-up dialog
which doesn't really work I think in
most cases on a mobile device that's
true it's harder to write code that way
it's a little harder to manage the
activity stack and it doesn't buy you
anything does it yeah there's nothing to
get anything extra for it right so the
and the other thing too is that if you
put it in a full screen activity then
all of the navigation has sort of been
done for you by the framework good
example of this would be the alarm clock
app where you also have to set a you
know date and time and they just have a
you know full screen and done hmm lisa
lee do now i think yeah thank you i
think they didn't before actually indeed
i think they used to be more of those
pop-ups but it's it's a trend that we're
seeing more and more of in mobile sort
of design is getting rid of dialogues in
all places and having our full screen
activities whenever you can no now this
is great this is uh it's showing me you
know where i can go i'm gonna have so if
i do cafe i'm going to have a layover in
hong kong which is great cafes cafes
always take that every story then yeah
oh yeah well I've never been able to
take Emirates you know why why is that
I'm not special Oh based in the US
you'll get used to it this is you don't
get any good service on the UN I moved
here and then suddenly like all of the
good Airlines Singapore emirates car
a ya know not so much a new zealand is
like the best way to get back home yeah
I'm not sure what that says but it's
nothing good yeah just don't fly
Northwest that's home soon um anyway so
layover in Zurich and then you know etc
etc so that's a nice stuff and it's
again it's listed by agony so I can also
really nice to say I really like what
they're what they're showing here it
feels like the the actual way that
they've implemented the layout here
isn't quite as nice as it could be now
they've got something which is
incredibly useful I mean this is I think
one of the real selling points of the
app is just how useful the screen is but
you know if you look at things like the
you know the prices along prices along
the left here then it all feels a little
bit cramped in there's not enough
spacing around the elements each of the
line items see it's just a little bit
too little like a rose need to just be a
little bit higher i think you know sort
of 40 a pixel rhythm you know follow the
sort of design guideline ideas that we
have there and that will just make it
feel a little bit more natural hear it
even though it's not it feels cramped
you know some of the fonts are a bit too
small some of the touch targets are a
bit too small just be fair they are
they're trying to present a lot of
information absolutely I and in their
defense they do have some really good
zooming yes you can see that as they
zoom it it actually feels very intuitive
you know things are getting bigger but
they're getting bigger in ways that are
useful to me it that aren't exactly what
I would get if it was just a naive zoom
now you can see these things resizing in
more of a smart way yeah so overall I
like it the one thing I would like is a
few more options here to filter by
things like frequent flyer miles because
if you're going even if you only take
one trip a year if it's this long you
want to figure out some frequent flyer
thing absolutely okay so nice app few
issues let's go ahead and take a look at
kayak shall we absolutely
alright so kayak I thought was not
really a great design from the UI
standpoint it certainly doesn't feel at
all like an Android app when you get
into it for the first time there's no
action bar there's this notifications
button down here that's way way too
small and it's down at the bottom where
I'm going to probably miss it it's it
and then it's not even a button it's
kind of a drawer and the reverse drew
it's an interesting pattern that it was
popular for a little while until people
realized it's kind of counterintuitive
you know the drawer comes down from the
top doesn't write it slide up from the
body you know and I'm not even gonna
complain too much except fit it's tiny
and it should at least have some
indication that it's a drawer damp so
all it's got is a little gradient on it
which we hate anyway and also it's got
the the anti room in narok pattern right
Chevron's absolutely and it is not the
gradient field header with the the title
in the center which again is room at
your AG anti-pattern yeah now to be fair
I don't get an iOS vibe off of this as
much as I guess his kayak branding blush
so I'm I'm good with that but you know
it's a little unnecessary now when I
actually search it gives me a progress
bar that apparently they poured it over
from gingerbread one thing that I loved
about it was earlier when I was inside
the Faraday cage and had no conductivity
whatsoever I actually tried this and
turns out that progress bar goes at a
constant speed hits ninety-nine percent
and then just stopped problems abuzz
ahad yes I probably a bar was not the
greatest idea I think so a progress
circle spinnerette if you don't know how
long it's gonna take and this is this is
a genuine problem often you just you
just don't know no you don't want to
have that kind of the old Microsoft joke
where it's like you know five minutes
two days three hours you know right it's
not good if you don't know that's fine
just have a spinner have something which
is basically implies with work is being
done rest assured but we don't know how
long it's exactly if you don't know how
long do unless you are actually trying
to teach Zeno's paradox
sure that would work alright so we get
into this uh once again we get some
branding here which is I think
attractive um feels a little odd to me
given that we have very little space on
this device so all of the rounding and
drop shadows and craziness is going on
there feels a little bit like wasted
space too but I think that's a matter of
opinion yeah I think my biggest concern
looking at this is more just the the
plethora of gradients and gradients with
reverse gradients to imply selection if
that that bar up the top here just looks
you know kind of weird that's true it's
actually really difficult to see what
your selection is yeah and then of
course we've got from from gradient land
down to ugly ugly system dialogue land
yeah why plus you know this idea that
you'll lose on safe progress don't tell
me that I'm going to lose progress just
make it so that I don't lose progress
right exactly it's again it's the you're
holding it wrong that's not the way this
app works don't don't do it this way if
you have enough users who are using the
app wrong that you feel the need to tell
them that they're using the app wrong
maybe they're not the ones that are
wrong I'm just saying right so anyway
let's um you know so it's got a lot of
the the features that you expect I think
they're all done relatively well I don't
know who this map provider is buying but
you know they say this scene be all
right up and coming you know whatever
it's doing hard I this plus and minus
zoom buttons I think we're maybe stolen
from somewhere yeah that looks actually
looks like mono in fairness I think
that's the the default control that you
can apply to any map or indeed anything
so that's you know it just looks kind of
old school but I think that's uh yeah
all right there at the Android what's
really there with the gradient well i
think it was was for backing gingerbread
land ah ok that could be wrong all right
well it looks absolutely i mean i
apologize so uh again here you know you
got the rounded corners uh you know i
don't know i don't want to hate on that
it looks good the main question I had
when I saw those is is it going to
perform well and the truth is yes it
performs a really really well this is
very very fast on this ginger jelly bean
phone so can't really complain about it
it does have the right Chevron's which
bother us just because we feel like in
android it should be apparent to
everyone that items in a list can be
clicked on to get more stuff and if you
have a chevron it sort of implies that
there's something special about that
chevron as opposed to the rest of the
list item and that's very rarely the
case yeah and if it is the case then you
should actually separate it out and
maybe consider using something more
descriptive than a chevron for it the
main problem though that I have with
kayak is at some point it removes its
Android mask and reveals itself for what
it really is which is the front end to a
bunch of lousy websites well you're not
Laos allow certainly not then upped
optimized for mobile yeah so all of a
sudden I'm back in a web browser
thinking well wow why did I download
this app it's just it's just a bunch of
bookmarks yeah why would you download an
app that's just a bookmark all right but
again we do have a lot of nice features
yeah yeah on track of here we've got you
know currency conversion to a lot of the
stuff that you want to have and use
while you're on the go I mean one thing
which I would point out here that so in
this implementation they don't have a
real action bar or at least they don't
always use it and so you've got this
list view which is kind of a dashboard
pattern but as a list so it kind of
skirts the you know the guidelines there
yeah it is my ask myself how does this
all fit together it seems like what we
don't is put a grab bag of really
interesting functionality I'm sorry I
didn't mean to step on this foot that's
alright that's alright yeah this whole
this whole standing up thing is going to
take some of mine used to yeah so the
problem is you've got a grab bag of
functionality all of which seems useful
but none of which really does a task for
me it's not a task oriented interface
what I really need is something that's
going to take me through the entire
process you know where do you want to go
how do you want to get there what do you
want to do when you're there here's
where the holes are you know you forgot
to get transportation from this flight
to this hotel what are you doing yeah
exactly and even here like you look
you're looking at the assassin there's
just an overwhelming number of things
that you can do whereas I think
everything once you get past and almost
price alerts really airline directory
airline fees airport information
preferences my location watching tweets
from kayak feedback about all of that
seems like it isn't really the purpose
of the app it just becomes a distraction
you know you're just flicking through
here going oh wow there's a lot of stuff
that this can do I'm really only going
to look at the first three because
everything beyond that is just too right
you've got these this whole list of
extra features is like oh thank god
they're in this app because it's not
like I have a smartphone hear anything
exactly right so here's my advice first
make the booking part of this app more
task oriented more oriented around
planning an entire trip as opposed to
interacting with different modes of
travel second why not figure out what
the user needs at the particular time if
I'm sitting at home I probably want to
do some booking if I'm out on the road
already especially if I'm inside of a
trip you know during a trip that you
know about because I booked it through
your app why not give me all of the
features that are down here at the
bottom yeah then exactly yeah try and
basically you've got all of this
information you are running on this
person smartphone you know a lot about
them just from the information which you
have got from their bookings if nothing
else so you really want to try and
contextualize your app based on what it
is that people are likely to be using
what they're likely to be trying to do
absolutely all right well let's go ahead
and take a look at a couple more now you
had a look at fast booking yeah and I
think we we already looked at several of
the features in this app how do you feel
about the UI so again you know this this
UI looks really kind of
it's kind of interesting because it's it
is flat which is nice I'm kind of like
this the the flat idea in Android but
again it feels like it's a little bit
too cramped like all the details that
we've got underneath these almost tabs
at the top are tiny tiny little fonts so
the degree we probably can't even see it
online and I'd like to make that
information bigger you know this is kind
of key data it's you check-in dates how
many nights he's staying how many people
it's all of the filters that you want to
apply well this is something that always
kind of kills me is if you go back to
the main screen look at all this area
down down here right you got a huge
amount of oh my god is an area that says
I don't have any results to show you
well you know what awesome look at all
that space that you can use to make your
interface less cramped and what a great
opportunity to get your user started on
a task instead I start the app by
feeling inadequate already because
there's all this fit space that I
haven't filled and then I need to figure
out these little tiny buttons up at the
top is to be fair they're not completely
tiny but they're still pretty small yeah
let's see hey guy hey where's that dog
very lucky it's gonna come back and
sweet haha some and so again so you've
got this weird combination between
having tiny tiny little null font and
then a large amounts of white space like
if you're looking over in this section
here again white space and we've got
these pictures which is nice but the
pictures are tiny so you almost want to
do something you know maybe even a full
bleed effect so it's just basically
pictures with text over it I don't know
how all that work but I think it's cool
it's a way to try and you know get rid
of some of the white space and replace
it with useful information yeah i think
really to boil down what rato saying is
that if you look at modern apps right
now that are visually oriented you will
see that the trend is to make the
pictures much bigger and much more a
part of the UI and people like that I've
done it looks great usually once you
sort of navigating you can see here
we've got this scrolling gallery of
pictures absolutely just wonderful and
there's you've got these resources and
this is something that I think this app
better than most of the ones we looked
at is really showing off the pictures
and having a big gallery of things for
each new place you're right but I'll
tell you if if this had been created by
for instance some of the photo people
that we talked to last week you know
what I think you'd be seeing on that
thing that you just switched away from I
think that this entire area here they
the area with a the the caption yeah
would be semi-transparent over the top
of the picture I think you might be
right yeah I think they would make use
that opportunity to make the picture a
lot bigger exact I mean the picture here
is what's selling it right i mean we've
got this big block of text which you
will read but if you've sort of flicking
through a bunch of different hotel
options it's the pictures which is going
to is going to make you stop and
actually find out if they're if the room
offers features that you want as well as
looking great you know again we've kind
of got these non-standard tabs along the
top it feels like you could do better
just using a sort of something like a
view pager or at least sort of more
standard tabs gallery has sort of began
unnecessary white space great
opportunity to have something really
rich and engaging yeah yeah the west
coast serve as a shame really is so this
is interesting so we've got the the star
affordance which is the right way to
indicate that you know you want to save
something or like something inside of
Android but you know again we're using
toasts along the bottom to notify folks
of what you've done again you shouldn't
really need to tell people well yeah
that what it feels a does spoke toes
exactly feels like the programmer want
to make sure that something was actually
done the all you need to do is fill in
the star which is what they did
excelling in the star says yeah we've
start you know likewise once we navigate
through we can see that the the UH
performance isn't being used at the top
here so that's you know given that this
is a standard actually bar it would be
nice to see that being done otherwise
yeah I mean that's the thing we've got
the we've got the Chevron's here which
again we would prefer not to see so I
think that's the key thing do they do
anything different i mean if i press the
chevron does it do any
died i believe so yeah it's it's kind of
the Simon you can actually see here that
the scroll bar is over the top level and
this da chevron so that's yeah so we'd
say you know the chevron isn't doing
anything it's just confusing the user
there are you I designs that are not
Android wear the Chevron is important
but the but those systems generally have
a very strong right word yeah flow right
it's like everything moves and write it
kind of makes sense well that's with
Android you don't necessarily know that
it's what it's going to do and it could
be different based on platform versions
or even carrier implementations yeah but
otherwise so I think that's the big
feedback there I think it could do you
know you've got great information useful
functionality it just needs a little bit
of a UI refresh to make a little bit
more richer a bit more engaging
absolutely so I think we've got a couple
more minutes we want to get a chance to
you know do an overview of each of the
apps but the last one words a look at
what is tripadvisor which I really quite
like you know so again it's it's a very
similar sort of look to kayak when we
open it up here you've got hotels
restaurants flights forums near me now
my saves and write a review so again
here they've cut it off a tab it's about
a page is worth which is nice and
there's none of the extra stuff the
extra stuff lives here in the overflow
menu and in fact some of them are
duplicated so near me now my saves are
both also in the overflow so you think
you need them in both places could you
save some space by moving these off the
main menu and tools I think they've got
a basically links to other apps which is
I think going on the model you were
suggesting earlier do you need to bundle
a currency converter or can you just
include a link to an app which does that
specifically yeah I mean maybe it's a
checkbox or people in blue yeah and so
fur tripadvisor they've got city guides
so this is a you know that full service
model which we were talking about so
that you know you're in a place you want
to get the guides find out what to do
you can download their city guides to
get that extra information so they're
using the appropriate search which is
nice if you navigate through again
they're not really using the UH
performance in the way we would expect
in a big branding big tripadvisor up
along the top in the action bar I
personally kind of prefer to see this
changed around so that they're just
using the icon
then using the UH performance to help
with navigation yeah the truth is the
having tripadvisor in the title bar
probably isn't important at all you have
a very distinctive icon and just using
the icon with some useful text there
instead of tripping on you know tell me
where I am in the app for instance early
or use that space for button because
that's where I think the the app falls
down a little bit is that in terms of
navigation it's very difficult to know
where you are where you've been and what
ways you can back out of things you know
we're just here we've gone through three
levels of depth here and there's sort of
no indication that we're anywhere other
than the beginning of the app similarly
view you sort of look at this display
you've got kind of a mismatch or a myth
yeah like a mismatch of different UI
styles you've got these buttons with the
sort of glassy gradient which are way
too small and that the touch targets
here are much too small and the
attractions of the top here just above
it in tiny tiny font which is actually
really difficult to touch looks like a
web toolbar right there does yeah well
and then let's talk about the tabs above
it was you know I wouldn't use this word
often but they looking amateur they do
they've got kind of the gradient reverse
gradient pressing them is really slow
feels and I rather suspect this might be
the case that this is actually at least
some of this is actually a web view
right which is fine like implementing it
as such if you've already got those
skills but you want it to be really
responsive and fast and clicking on each
of these takes a fair while before it'll
flick over and we don't we don't get any
sort of the viewpager functionality you
know these are scrawled which again is
probably fine but one thing I did want
to highlight here at the bottom is this
see 20 more don't make me press it once
they get to the bottom just blowed it
I'm down the bottom presumably I want to
see more so it should sort of be able to
keep track of where I am in the list and
automatically dynamically start bringing
in that extra content no not when I get
there well we were over ambitious today
we chose five apps to take a look at and
that's too much yeah but you know
whatever we had fun and it's not like
anybody else need this room after us
right oh no in fact it's not like we're
postponing you know the new episode of
Grey's Anatomy or something heavens of
it that still a thing I don't I think it
may be thing I think there was a plane
crash I don't know
alright let's take a look at the final
scores all right so final scores for the
apps today so let's have a look we're so
these are the prescriptions just to
remind everyone because it seems like it
was a long time ago that we had these
last on screen so this is what we're
going to be judging each of the apps on
I think we're using exciting star
ratings today is that right absolutely
well you know I got I got tired of
trying to decode the colors so I you
know world skip webcams did not score
well in this particular round up mostly
because it turned out it wasn't actually
the type of app we're looking for and
also I think there was a bad call by the
refs topical it has a relatively
consistent user interface but it's not
very good at following the Android UI
guidelines especially using a view pager
that's not really a view pager instead
of a navigation drop-down which is kind
of what it actually was and the rest of
it you know we're just gonna skip
because it's not that out not that I
things go ahead and go on to hit monk on
the other hand uh much more consistent
with the design guide then a lot of the
absolutely looked out we gave it three
stars just because it didn't have a
really consistent use of icons they got
some of the text completions
horrifically wrong and they're on record
saying that the main thing they did for
Android was taking the rounded corners
off because Android can't do rounded
corners so feel like they can be fair
they came and apologized in person for
that but still all right but really
really excellent app we're looking
forward to seeing the update on the web
so they've got a very nice functionality
kayak course is about as consistent as
as Hipmunk well yeah you know I soon a
knocked off one more star here they
should have had an action bar and I
really wish they'd get rid of that
lengthy lengthy list of all the things
that the app you absolutely when we
talked about this a lot and that's focus
it's a really important thing when
you're developing an app for a
smartphone is figure out what it is that
your app does which is the most
important thing and make that front and
center even at the cost of an alumina
some of your functionality people tend
to install your app for the main thing
it does not because oh well I was
choosing between kayak and TripAdvisor
but kayak had a currency converter so
that's why I kept it around right it's
probably pretty unlikely exactly I feel
like people are missing a golden
opportunity actually why not just
install that separately hey hey by kayak
you also get this correct pretty
converter absolutely the other thing
that it does is it doesn't complete
transactions on your device it just
sends you to the web I can kind of the
web from any device and I didn't I
didn't need this app to send me there so
let's take a look at the last two then
so if I like that the stars are moving
around as we hit the button that's kind
of completely unintentional I think it
was hahahaha so fast booking again we
kind of got that the same issue with the
consistency with the design guide it
feels like they're pretty close they're
using an action bar they've got a kind
of a flat UI I think they just need to
look at their spacing you know look to
have more more images front and center
and I think they can really take this
and take it up to the next level and
possibly rethink the color scheme a
little bit because you've got a very
light named color on white and grey and
it's a little bit not contrast e enough
yeah it could be the whole thing could
just be have a little more punch right
and the last appt was uh was tripadvisor
of course and so they did pretty well
they got a lot of stars going on here um
good Guster's we were the way it was the
end of the night we were both drunk and
we were just giving out stars like
laughter anyone home it does pretty well
it does your entire trip it's very
location aware does the the transactions
on the device itself again I think they
could do a little bit more with the
design guide just to take it that that
little bit further make it a little bit
more rich and consistent absolutely okay
poof alright so that was fun let's not
do that let's not do that against
interesting so if we could switch to the
to the full screen view of us as we say
goodbye um nice so two of these apps are
going to be looked up by Roman Nick and
Adam on Android design in action that's
kayak and world scope webcams are both
getting the Android design in action
makeover next tuesday morning so do tune
in for that and stay tuned because i
know that at least some of these apps
Hipmunk in a couple i believe that a
couple others are are updating soon and
so we'll be able to see what they do in
response to some of the design
guidelines that we've shared with them
already absolutely and we'll be inviting
all the developers from the apps that we
looked at today to join us next week for
the developer strike back next thursday
at eleven-thirty so if you guys if you
help build one of these apps and you
would like to tell us exactly what you
think about our feedback last night
we'll make sure to get you on the show
next week it starts with the app clinic
then Roman and his design guidelines
then developers strike back it is the
circle of app life absolutely we've also
got so next week at the app clinic we're
going to do video players I think is the
plan yet exactly and we are actually
going to settle on those right after
this show we're going to give ourselves
a week I think that that's possibly a
little ambitious because i don't think
the moderator paid exists yet so it may
be difficult for people to have have
nominated their apps but we'll see if it
does exist and people have nominated
them we will certainly be choosing them
if not then do get on quickly because as
soon as we have three to four likely
candidates we will be choosing those to
give us enough time to really get into
these apps and and try and dig a little
bit deeper that's right so get out there
get on that moderator page hit refresh a
lot hit refresh like you're going for
google i/o tickets that's a lot of
refreshing oh we're going to take off
we've we've kept you guys for long
enough I think we have the Friday games
review coming up let it sit absolutely
the games review is going to be it I
believe 2 p.m. yeah i dares is they're
playing the times they're playing with
those they're playing with a lot who
knows what's gonna happen it's gonna be
crazy in any case oh yeah chi nhanh for
that we'll be back for a bunch of shows
but we'll certainly be back hopefully
see you guys next week for the app
clinic I'm ruta maya i'm ian ni-lewis
we'll see you later
you